>> From the library of
congress in Washington, D.C.
[ Silence ]
>> ERIC FRAZIER:
It is my pleasure
to introduce Paul Holbrook to
our [inaudible] lecture series.
It's. Today we have here Dr.
Paul Evans Holbrook to speak
to us about the victor
[inaudible] collection
and there is perhaps no
one more knowledgeable
about victor [inaudible] than
Mr. Holbrook, Dr. Holbrook.
He became close friends
with Caroline about 2 years
after victor passed away
and he was instrumental
in getting the victor
[inaudible] collection,
victor and Caroline
[inaudible] collection here
to the library of congress.
This all started about, well at
least for us here, our interest
and our relationship with Paul
started about 4 years ago.
He stopped by to pick
up some materials
from the collection itself
and as he was going through,
it was just, he was,
it's obvious he was the
curator for the collection.
He's picking up [inaudible]
and saying yes,
this is the mantel piece that
belongs in the church and I,
when I picked my job off
the floor, I was, you know,
I was really thrilled that
somebody knew the collection
so well and then at the same
time I was really disappointed
that he was on a flight
back to Kentucky that night.
And so, we've been working with
Paul to reclass the collection
and this is why it's so
important that he's back here
to help us, to help
us understand,
to help curate this
collection, get it in front
of the people who
need to see it.
So, we have a keepsake that
you're holding right now.
This is from the crooked crow
press, Chris Manson's press,
and he's part of APHA,
the American Print
History Association.
And so, you may see that we have
2 dates on here; April 26th,
of course today, and
April 27th, tomorrow.
Tomorrow, Dr. Holbrook
will be giving a talk
to APHA specifically and that's
why you'll see 2 dates on there.
We're not missing anything
or that wasn't a typo.
Though don't look too closely
because we set some
of the [inaudible].
This is a beautiful
piece despite the fact
that [inaudible] helped
produce it, but not because of.
So, Dr. Holbrook edited
a collection of letter
between the [inaudible]
and Thomas [inaudible].
Curated shows the victor's work
and continues the [inaudible]
work and legacy as a printer
and director of the
King Press Library
at the university of Kentucky.
Please help me to welcome
Dr. Paul Evans Holbrook.
[ Background noise ]
>> DR. PAUL EVANS HOLBROOK:
Thank you very much.
Raise your hand if
you can't hear me.
Am I all right with you?
Tomorrow, I'm talking mostly
about printing types although a
few other things will work their
way in and today I'm talking
not so much about victor's work
as a typographer and printer,
but will be happy to do
so in discussion with you
after my presentation.
Today my hope is to introduce
you to victor [inaudible]
and his work and then when I
have done so, you will feel
as if you have met him.
In a letter of May, the 25st,
1951, the poet Wallace Stevens
with whom [inaudible] had
an extensive correspondence
and for whom victor
created an [inaudible],
humorously suggested the life
and times of a contrary man
as a suitable title
for [inaudible] book
which was badly entitled as
Memory and her nine daughters,
the muses, a pretext for
printing cast into the mold
of a dialogue in 4 chapters.
It was badly entitled because I
as a sometime bibliographer have
had to write the entire title
or type it numerous
times, too long.
I, being in the process
of writing a biography
of [inaudible] at the request
of his late wife Caroline,
with whom I worked for 30 years,
and considering using this title
humorously suggested by Stevens
as the subtitle of my
biography of [inaudible].
[inaudible] himself says in
the dialogue lengthily titled,
truly I'm, you labeled
me the contrary man,
but you did not say
contrary to what.
Truly I'm contrary to mediocrity
though I know we could not live
on the planet without it.
I'm contrary to sloth and
contrary to waste which will go
on in spite of me
and I'm contrary
to blasphemy against the spirit.
I have proved to myself
that I can change the world,
that only within the
reach of my hands.
The work I leave behind will
not be great yet it will prove
to be genuine, genuine
though not progressive.
[inaudible] poets in ancient
India saw that all elements
of the divine, human and natural
world fit together perfectly
in an eternal and smoothly
flowing symbolism known
as [inaudible].
Despite their powerful
and diverse personalities,
even the gods and goddesses
lived within the structure
of this cosmic law
of universal harmony.
With intuitive flash of
imagination, the poet
or artist was able to see
the unified harmonious nature
of reality and to be afforded
access to the creative powers
that imagined the real.
The sand script word
[inaudible] suggests the smooth
and rhythmic turning of the
wheel of being and is derived
from the proto-Indo-European
root, ar,
meaning fit together
properly, suitably united.
This serves as the basis
for the Greek word harmous,
the root of harmony and also
the basis for the Latin ar's,
root of art and artist.
The [inaudible] sages who
saw [inaudible] within
and behind all forms of being
saw the art of existence itself
and allowed their
artistry and craft
to focus the creative power
and thereby to present
that order fixed
for contemplation.
[ Background noise ]
>> DR. PAUL EVANS HOLBROOK:
Victor [inaudible] life
as an artist and craftsman is
a testament to that vision.
It is an understanding that
very early became a part
of [inaudible] tacit awareness.
As he writes in his last book,
I was born into the 18th century
yet I was not consciously aware
of this fact for
a very long time.
I first opened my eyes in and
onto one of the oldest parts
of Vienna, the Vienna
of Maria Teresa.
My father and mother had chosen
to live in this old sector
of time not because
it was beautiful,
but because the rents
were low for not one
of the houses had more than the
simplest conveniences to offer.
I was born in [inaudible],
but my earliest recollections,
all of them visual, hinge
on the place we occupied
in the [inaudible].
These first few years of my
childhood in the last quarter
of the 19th century have
formed by view of the world
as an artist and have modeled
it in the character of the art
of the late 17th and
early 18th centuries.
I had no chance, nor had I
being then a little oy not
yet in school, the capacity
for realizing that all things
that surrounded me were
already over 200 years old.
This world into which I was
born and in which I began
to live was a world
contemporary with me.
I saw no other.
It was a world built of
the demand of the people
who lived more than 2 centuries
before me, a world shaped
and raised by their
builders and artists,
a world of artistic achievements
was the only world of which I,
at this early age, was aware.
It was self-evident and
beyond all question.
I had never heard of art,
would not have understood the
word nor could I have conceived
of quality and achievement, but
I looked upon the altar pieces
in the Jesuit's church,
it's ceiling with a fresco
by Padre Patso and
[inaudible] of the university.
I absorbed and accepted,
unknowingly.
I am a genuine anachronism.
The rear of the Jesuit's
church, it's apse,
gave on the [inaudible], the
front gave on the [inaudible].
The house in which we lived
was separated from the church
by a narrow passageway
only allowed to pedestrians
as it opened through
no more than a doorway
into the [inaudible]
where the church stood.
I liked to play or just
to be in this place.
Every time I stepped through
the small doorway into this roof
without a ceiling through
4 well-ordered walls,
the site of it cleared my
breath, made me feel free.
Even the memory of it
has the same affect.
This well-ordered space was
the womb which nurtured the art
of victor [inaudible] in his
youth and set the trajectory
that allowed his vision to
develop throughout his lifetime.
[inaudible] attended 4 years of
the Jesuit's elementary school,
already showing a vivid
interest in drawing,
painting and the crafts.
Because of his artistic
bent as he grew older,
his father became
concerned about his future,
fearing that life as an
artist could not be a
serious profession.
At 14, after 4 years
of secondary school
with increases competence as
a draftsman, several drawings
of his family including a
portrait of his grandfather
which had recently
gained familial favor,
finally convinced his father
that his artistic
ambitions were serious.
No longer opposing
victor's future plans,
Carl [inaudible] arranged for
his apprenticeship in the studio
of the well-known
architect, art historian
and urban planner,
[inaudible] in 1897.
After a year of realizing
victor's potential, he suggested
that he should apply to
the academy of fine arts.
He was accepted and
studied painting
with professor [inaudible].
Later he switched to sculpture
classes with professors Helmer,
[inaudible] and [inaudible].
[ Background noise ]
>> DR. PAUL EVANS HOLBROOK:
He was very much attracted
to sculpture but soon realize
that his true métier
was to be painting.
As he said, I could not
afford to be a sculptor
and I knew I could make
my way as a painter.
Though when I looked at a
finished work, I am always aware
that I painted with
a sculptor's eye.
My painted figures
looked to be carved.
He left the academy after 7
semesters saying professor
[inaudible] was glad to be
rid of me as glad as he was
to have rid himself
of [inaudible].
He worked alone for a year
when professor [inaudible] work
and took him into his classes
where he remained for 4 years.
While there, he participated
for the first time
in a public exhibition
with the [inaudible],
an artist organization, in 1907.
His portrait of a woman
was received positively
by the press and critics.
His next success came in 1908
when he was awarded the
[inaudible] for a portrait
of Rosa [inaudible], his future
wife, which allowed him to marry
and to travel to Paris, Munich,
and for the first time to Italy.
He also won the [inaudible],
permitting further traveling.
They spent the winter
of 1909 and 10 in Munich
and became acquainted
with the circle
around Adolf von [inaudible], a
friend of the artist [inaudible]
and the art theorist
Conrad [inaudible].
[inaudible] writes in 1910
or 11, I had an interview
with Adolf von [inaudible].
His book, the problem of
form, had fascinated me,
but I felt I did not
understand it and hoped
that he would explain
part of it to me.
He tried, but after quite
a long talk together,
I was still groping
for my answers.
Finally, I asked a question
which I thought was pertinent,
after all, is not the
most important part
of the portrait painter's
task the representation
of the psyche of the sitter.
With a flash in his
eyes, he hurled a reply,
how can you say such a thing.
I was shocked and crushed,
but my eyes had been opened.
In time, I understood.
Because of his contact with
[inaudible], he said of his stay
in Munich, this experience
brought by a deep
and lasting spiritual
stimulation.
From [inaudible], he began to
understand the problem of form
in a clearer light with
form as the primary concern
of the artist, but it
would be several years
until his understanding became
visible in his paintings.
[inaudible] had been painting
of rather large canvases
and a colleague suggested
smaller,
more intimate portraits
more likely to be bought
and fitting more easily
in domestic settings.
Indeed, [inaudible]
received more
and more private commissions.
The [inaudible] ought a portrait
[inaudible] in an easy chair
at which time he also took
up book binding in order
to supplement his
income as an artist.
This is a portrait
of [inaudible],
done in almost art nuevo style.
She was a dancer, I mean,
well dancer and singer
in the Viennese Operetta.
In 1912, he exhibited a
collection in the succession.
It was an important success
critically and financially
and he was elected a
member of the succession
and joined regular
commissions thereafter.
From 1907 until world war 1, he
exhibited regularly at galleries
in Vienna, in Berlin at
the gallery [inaudible]
and in Munich at the
gallery [inaudible].
He was mentioned positively,
almost unanimously,
in publications.
Only once was he
criticized for his quote,
sharp and rigidly
drawn portraits
which lacked liveliness.
[inaudible] resigned from the
Viennese succession in 1913,
realizing he had
really nothing in common
with the other secessionist even
though they were his classmates
at the academy.
Indeed, [inaudible],
who recently had a show
at the Neue Gallery in New
York, had been his studio mate
at the time of [inaudible]
tragic suicide following his
affair with Matilda [inaudible].
This is a [inaudible]
self-portrait with clarinet
in oil showing still bound to
the Viennese style of 1900.
In his studies, victor had
copied portraits of [inaudible]
and the Italian masters
as well as [inaudible]
of the Austrian Biedermeier,
whom he admired very much.
In all the early portraits,
[inaudible] technique differed
from that of his
later paintings.
He painted in oil instead of
egg tempera and in a much freer
and quicker way, finishing
after only a few sittings.
[inaudible] completed 2
early portraits of his friend
and patron, [inaudible]
as well as a couple
of self-portraits all in
oil, this being one of them.
[inaudible] had been a road
scholar at Oxford together
with Alexander [inaudible].
[ Background noise ]
>> DR. PAUL EVANS
HOLBROOK: By 1914,
there was movement toward the
later style with the portraits
of Helen [inaudible]
and his great friend
and patron, Conrad [inaudible].
This is the portrait
of [inaudible].
She is dressed in green.
Unfortunately, we don't
seem to have a color copy.
Both portraits display
his meticulous treatment
of every detail, a facet
of all future work,
but he says I can only give my
sitter's head the best place
on the panel.
The portraits of Conrad and Ana
[inaudible] each display letter
forms, announcing the subject's
name and date of completion.
[inaudible] often continues
this painting of letter forms
in his work in the medieval
and early renaissance
style in various portraits.
[inaudible] writes in May
of 1914, I was invited
by [inaudible] to
come to Florence
and paint a portrait
of his wife.
I worked very hard on this
portrait in the few weeks
at their Villa in
[inaudible] near Florence,
was a very lovely
time in my life.
I was able to take a trip
by car through Umbria
and the total experience
filled me with pure happiness.
Faith had apparently
given me this peaceful
and happy interlude
out of charity
for before I could start my new
work, the world war broke out.
I reported for duty in
[inaudible], Poland,
on the [inaudible]
river as an infantryman.
He spent 4 months in combat
with the 4th Austrian
infantry regiment.
In October, he would be sent
to guard duty behind the lines
and then to headquarters as a
staff artist in the [inaudible].
After the war, [inaudible] was
sent to [inaudible] and then
to Constantinople before
returning to Vienna.
He writes, the first work I
did after this army life was
as though my artistic
ability was paralyzed.
In the first year at the
academy, my work was better.
In 1918, [inaudible] began a
work pivotal to the development
of his technique, the wood
turners of Constantinople.
Even for his standard, he
did an amazing large number
of preparatory studies.
Even though he came ack to
the panel numerous times
in the following
years, the panel started
in egg tempera was
never finished.
Nevertheless, the panel is
of particular importance
because it shows
a new development
in [inaudible] work
unlike the portraits he did
for the [inaudible] museum,
the arsenal gallery of Vienna.
Although his panel still shows
a scientific 3-dimensional
perspective, which is not
found in the later works,
the figures no longer
seem captured
in a temporary situation,
but seem arrested
in their movement
in a timeless space.
As [inaudible] says, the work
of art, the genuine work,
opens the eyes of the
beholder to see reality anew,
prepared for contemplation.
By 1918, [inaudible] had
returned to his studio in Vienna
which he would maintain
until 39.
The [inaudible] now
had a son and daughter.
Post war Austria suffered
from hunger, cold,
the constant currency
devaluation
and shattered self-confidence.
The political situation
in the young republic
was tense and uncertain.
The fear of overwhelming
communism was in the air.
People thought that
only an annexation
by Germany could save the
situation, but it was not
until 1938, until the
[inaudible] became a reality.
As a result, the [inaudible]
decided to go to the country,
to [inaudible], where they met
Dr. [inaudible] and his wife
who helped him find lodging.
[ Background noise ]
>> DR. PAUL EVANS HOLBROOK:
They developed a
long-lasting friendship.
[inaudible] was a passionate
Latinist, quickly attracted
to the well-educated painter.
They were able to store some
of [inaudible] possessions
including letters,
in safekeeping during
world war 2.
Around 1920, the [inaudible]
family left [inaudible]
at the invitation of his friend
and patron Ferdinand [inaudible]
to stay at his estate in
Saint Martin in [inaudible]
where they continued to
summer for a decade or so.
Rudolph [inaudible], the great
German typographer, calligrapher
and craftsman describes the
creative atmosphere during these
months and includes what then
about victor [inaudible].
Is he an artist?
Is he an artisan?
Neither word fits his case as
both are linked to concepts
which are refuted by him.
He is not a combination
of both either.
It is better to say that
he is neither of the 2.
For an artist, he is
too practically minded,
to sober, to normal.
There is nothing fanciful
or exalted about him.
For a craftsman, his
mind is too profound,
his intellectual
measure to great.
As early as 1910, [inaudible]
had been experimenting
with the technique
of the [inaudible],
and almost forgotten
discipling which his concern
for graphic preciseness,
proved to be an ideal
medium for the artist.
The technique had been widely
used for copying paintings
from the late 18th into the
second half of the 19th century,
especially in England
and in Austria.
In Saint Martin,
[inaudible] returned to it,
finishing the portrait of
[inaudible] depicting him
in a traditional
Austrian hunting outfit.
He later did a number
of illustrations
of traditional Austrian clothing
known as trachten for his friend
and patron, Conrad [inaudible].
In 1924, he extended his
skill in London where the arts
of the [inaudible]
was still taught
at the royal college of art.
Thereafter, he completed
a number
of [inaudible] including
a portrait
of [inaudible] government
head, Dr. Carl Maria Stephen,
pictured there in the hat,
Viennese operetta star
[inaudible] again,
although not here as
Madam [inaudible],
[inaudible] patrician of Baron
of whom he also made a portrait
in oil and tempera in 1924.
Victor von [inaudible],
professor of folklore
at the university of Graz,
Martha [inaudible] as well
as his friend, the
musicologist [inaudible] who is
down in the lower left
corner with whom he carried
on an extensive correspondence
about the parallel relationship
of form and structure in
music and the visual arts.
His own [inaudible]
self-portrait here
with the glasses and looking
over his shoulder
was complete in 1926.
The year 1922 marks
the beginning
of victor's most productive
period as an artist
which sees the crystallization
of his mature painting style.
The creation of his
first [inaudible] faces
and the establishment
of his printing press.
This is a version, an
early version, of Christ
and the adulteress, an image
which he painted 5 different
times over a long period
of years and our thinking
about it is he meditated
on [inaudible] suicide because
of Maria von [inaudible]
adultery and it was a way of
dealing with that tragedy.
Victor returned to Florence with
his family and set up his studio
and household in
October of 1922,
at first at the Villa
[inaudible] in Sophiono then
in the [inaudible]
in [inaudible]
where he became a neighbor
to Baroner [inaudible].
It was with the crystallization
of this mature style
in the portrait of
Madam [inaudible] shown
at the Venetian [inaudible] of
1924 with, and his own portrait
with Lute [inaudible] and
tuning fork and the portrait
of [inaudible], the
court of saint James,
that [inaudible] had
a realization crucial
to his self-understanding.
I just wanted to
point out the portrait
of the Swiss Madam
[inaudible] and the difference
in a color version and a
black and white version.
Victor always painted something
new in each of his portraits
and he was interested in
learning to paint a glass
or in this one which is
suspended on the chain along
which also you find his
printer's mark suspended
from the end of a chain.
It is a very interesting
medieval allegory going
on in the background in the,
and in the middle ground
with people doing
various things over here
and very interestingly,
Franciscan monk, a Jesuit,
I mean [inaudible], a figure, a
Christ like figure dangling down
and the adulteress
appearing once again.
[ Background noise ]
>> DR. PAUL EVANS HOLBROOK:
Back to [inaudible].
As a child, [inaudible]
had looked
out of his bedroom window
one morning and writes,
at one glass I absorbed all
the forms in front of me.
Their order, the contrast of
light and shadow, warm and cool
as it were, and the
relationship of planes.
I also saw the narrow street
coming from the left-hand side
and broadening into
the narrow square.
Through the open door
of the gate house,
I could see the sunlight
on the distant pavement
of the [inaudible].
The tiny belfry with its
cross on top stood clear
against a transparent sky.
Yellow sunlight already lay on
the roofs and the upper part
of the house walls while cool,
gray shade still filled
the narrow street.
Horizontal and vertical forms,
rough and smooth surfaces,
solid, tangible forms against
the sky, that was all there was,
nothing poetical, nothing
emotional, no yearning,
no great distance,
nothing idyllic.
Only quiet, clear
sensitively arranged forms.
After a short while, I left the
window and picked up the shreds
of a child's life where I
have left off the day before.
Many years passed and I was
nearing the middle of life.
I had forgotten what I
had seen as a little oy.
Sometimes at long
intervals, a recollection
of those moments
flash through my mind.
It soothed me while it lasted,
but no longer did it
mean anything to me.
When I was in London,
I was commissioned
by the Swiss minister to
the court of Saint James
to paint his portrait.
I made all his studies in London
then went back to Florence
to paint the panel there.
As Mr. [inaudible] was in
the garb of a minister,
I had a chosen a view of
the ambassador's court
in the Saint James palace
with a little white
tower as a background.
After I finished the painting,
I took it to London for delivery
and should it be necessary,
to give it final touches
in the presence of the model.
When I took it out of the box
and saw it with fresh eyes,
the recollection of what
I'd seen from the window
as a little boy came
back to me suddenly
and was more vivid
than ever before.
I realized that I had repeated
that scene in the painting,
horizontal plane alternating
with vertical ones,
quiet and moving masses,
clear and tangible forms
against a sky, a London sky,
gray and murky, in my portrait.
The tiny belfry, the
[inaudible] in the street,
everything was there, oddly
changed yet recognizable.
Even myself in the
person of the model.
Mentally, I reviewed
my past work.
I was both agitated and puzzled.
No doubt, here was a pattern
of composition which recurred
in all my work however disguised
in each particular one.
The subject matter had
no influence upon it,
whether a portrait, a historical
scene or a single figure,
I had cast it in the same mold.
The 3 latest large
self-portraits provide
understandable examples of this.
Not including, the 2
large ones with paintbrush
in one hand, different hands.
[ Background noise ]
>> DR. PAUL EVANS HOLBROOK:
Everything must be
comprehensible,
the depth clearly readable in
all parts of the depiction.
The occasion for the
picture is hardly thought of.
Since it is a portrait,
we do not want
to neglect the resemblance,
but it is only 1
requirement among many.
Clothing, objects, background
are chosen according to points
of view differing from those
thought of by the client
or by those later
perceived by the critics.
Everything is created to be
mutually interchangeable.
The characteristics of the live
image are carefully explored
in the many preparatory studies.
His individuality is
the starting point
of the construction, but the
construction is always the same.
We always seek to create the
same work of art according
to the same law and each time,
only its outward
appearance varies.
[inaudible].
Always the same, but
not in the same way.
Invoking the memory of
[inaudible] with whom
in their long correspondence,
there was so much
cross fertilization.
The book sellers
at the [inaudible] shows
perfectly an example
of the form, the geometry, to
which [inaudible] is essential,
refers as essential
to his compositions.
That underlying structure,
the remnant of his
childhood impressions.
Here is a triangle form by
the man pointing and speaking.
His head at the vertex
and the seated men turning
on the stool to listen.
The background is
skillfully arranged
to distract the eye
from the triangle.
The subjects are
arranged within the frame
on 3 independent planes,
foreground, middle plane
and background, all
resting on the ground plan.
[ Background noise ]
>> DR. PAUL EVANS HOLBROOK: This
later version of the adulteress.
[inaudible] uses overlapping
forms to create space
as the medieval painters did.
The fact that parts of a
whole are nearer to or farther
from the eye, that when falling
on one side they must
rise on the other.
In fact, that all this
happens within the framework
of foreground and background
and on a definite ground plan.
This is the whole content
of classic work of art.
To shape these events with
his hands is the true,
is to the true artist an
ever novel, never repeated,
always the same pure task.
It is what was accomplished
in the medieval workshop.
As he says, the medieval
artist was observant
of the rules of his craft.
The rules were not arbitrary.
They were not setup
for the convenience
of either the artist
or the patron.
When followed, these
rules attained an end,
a work of civilized art to fit
into a civilized
people's environment.
The patron was not
interested in the rules,
but in the end obtained what
[inaudible] ready to pay.
If he ordered an image
of Saint Sebastian,
he expected to get a picture
of a naked young man
spiked with arrows.
It was easy for the
artist to comply with this,
but to observe the rules
of the workshop was
quite a different thing.
Without it being laid
down expressly as a rule,
the concern for the workshop
was to make the saint visible,
visible to the beholder.
This was not a matter of
observation of nature,
of scientific watching
and scrutinizing,
nor was it a matter of
making concepts visible.
An old man with a white
beard and a halo served
for god the father and
human beings with wings
on their shoulders
served for angels.
The devil was always at
the bottom, never on top.
In modern terminology,
this was show business
and show people know what
affects an audience visually.
The medieval craftsman
knew it to.
[inaudible] was able to work out
his personal type of classic art
and to create a portrait style
valid for the rest of his life,
a development showing
its first visual outburst
in the timelessness
and graphic quality
of the wood turners of 1918.
The time in Florence from
1924 to 29 were a time
of serenity for [inaudible].
He completed numerous portraits
in [inaudible], Berlin, Munich,
Paris, [inaudible], London,
Strasburg and in Pittsburgh,
for his Patron Edgar
[inaudible].
He began cutting [inaudible],
setting up his printing
in [inaudible].
He also built together with
[inaudible] a carpenter,
2 clavichords as
prototypes for kids.
Albert [inaudible] had suggested
this idea to [inaudible]
since both were great components
of the clavichord
and the harpsichord.
Unfortunately, we will
probably never know the details
of this project because prior
to their departure from Vienna,
following the German
annexation in 1939, [inaudible]
and his wife Rosa burned a
number of letters in order
to protect their correspondence
after they had left Austria
including those of [inaudible].
In her book, 40 years
with [inaudible],
Nikki [inaudible] wrote,
[inaudible] had been introduced
to the Berenson's by one of
BB's old Austrian friends,
the collector Count
Lens [inaudible].
[inaudible] seemed to
belong to another century
in combining art
and artisanship.
An accomplished painter,
a printer of fine books,
a constructor of musical
instruments, his discussion
with Bb were sometimes
so profound and involved
that ordinary mortals
could not follow them.
Berenson was not
sympathetic to [inaudible]
at this time nor
ever, yet the family
and Nikki [inaudible] were
always the kindest of friends.
As [inaudible] himself records,
when I had finished
the self-portrait
with the tuning fork
which is usually mistaken
as a fever thermometer
at first sight,
dear kind Nikki [inaudible]
wanted me to show it to Berenson
for she liked it and she
said he might be interested
in seeing it.
I took the picture one
day over to [inaudible],
setting it in a chair
in Berenson's study.
What he said I do
not recall in full,
only one thing I remember
well, he said it looks like one
of those wooden painted statues
one sees in Spain on the altars
of churches and this
was and is true.
I did not take this criticism
as a complement at that time
and Berenson did not mean
it to be one, but now I see
that Berenson's judgement
was in a sense,
rather an involuntary
compliment.
For some argument, he pointed
to the Madonna of [inaudible]
that hung in the study
next to the window.
I saw immediately
the weak part in it
and said certainly not too
politely, but how can you stand
that left side of the mantle
falling down into nothing
against the firm
triangle of the child.
For a while he was
silent, realizing perhaps
for the first time that the bulk
of the child was not
counterbalanced by anything
on the opposite, the
left side, by anything
but the weak part of the mantle.
Then he continued, yes, I admit
this but what about the rest?
The question itself
was a wrong one.
If something in the whole
composition is wrong,
there is nothing left
for being any good.
Lovely though the child
is and the mother too.
Among musicians in Florence,
[inaudible] knew Adolf Bush
and Rudolph [inaudible]
who years later came
to see [inaudible] in
Lexington on 2 occasions.
He had bought the drawing
for the portrait of,
Victor's portrait of
Thomas [inaudible].
Through his Munich patrons the
[inaudible], he was introduced
to Carlo [inaudible], a
Florentine noble, novelist,
travel writer and figure
in the local literary life,
art collector [inaudible]
and lawyer
and American art
collector Carlo [inaudible].
Ulrich [inaudible], head
of the German art
institute, became a friend.
They would be reunited in
Chicago where [inaudible],
formerly head of the art
department at the University
of Chicago, arranged
an exhibition
for [inaudible] in 1948.
Through the Berenson, he met Sir
John Rosenstein whose wife was
from Lexington, Kentucky
and Kenneth Clark
who became a patron and friend.
Edward Ned Bruce, also an artist
and later in charge of the WPA
at the treasury department
was a kind friend
who brought his friends
to meet [inaudible],
among whom was [inaudible]
Huxley whose philosophy
[inaudible] admired.
Huxley saw [inaudible] many
years later in Lexington
when he lectured at
Transylvania University.
[ Background noise ]
>> DR. PAUL EVANS HOLBROOK:
[inaudible] drawings
of [inaudible] and
of Mary Berenson,
fine and firm images much work
over are almost speaking
images [inaudible].
[inaudible] writes of
another similar drawing
of Sir Frederick [inaudible].
In the early 1920's,
the Austrian minister Baron
[inaudible] invited him to come
to London and stay with him
at the embassy while I worked
on the drawing for his portrait.
He decided I should
make a drawing of one
of his acquaintances,
a very distinguished
looking gentleman at court.
This night, as we both
innocently believed result
in other conditions when
the drawing would be seen.
So, I made the drawing which
I recall was a silver point.
Sir Frederick accepted
it gracefully
and hoped its display
would be a success.
After a long while,
Baron [inaudible] asked
whether the drawing had
been appreciated.
Sir Frederick's reply was
that it may have been,
but though he could
lead horses to water,
he couldn't make them drink.
Years later in Lexington,
our good neighbor Mary
[inaudible] came one day
with a book for me, grace
and favor, the memoires
of the duchess of West Minster.
In this book was the drawing
I had made of her father.
His face had, she
said, the refinement
of a [inaudible] drawing.
She seems to have seen
him through my eyes
for my drawing had
the characteristics
of a [inaudible] drawing though
I did not have the benefit
of renaissance dress.
[inaudible] had been
interested in the book arts
since he began book binding
in 1911, hoping one day
to print and bind a book.
In Florence, he experimented
with cutting type eventually
created several [inaudible]
faces, the first being cut
in 1921 by Swiss type cutter.
1926, [inaudible]
and [inaudible],
son of Rudolph [inaudible],
began cutting a second
type face together.
It was cast by hand
in the studio in 1928
and would be called [inaudible]
after the first issue
from the press in 1931 and that
book is the second from the end
of the left side of the table.
Deciding that if he were
creating a type face
and using handmade paper,
he should also have a
handmade printing press.
In 1927, [inaudible] made some
drawings of a wooden press
in the bibliotheca [inaudible].
While still living
in the [inaudible],
his craftsman friend,
built the press.
Neighbor [inaudible] Berenson
suggested that in [inaudible],
appropriate first issue
of the press might be John
Milton's Samson Agonistes
for reasons unclear, but
that was the suggestion
and it was accepted.
At a luncheon party in 1929,
[inaudible] had a
fortuitous meeting
with Edgar [inaudible]
sr. at Pittsburgh.
[inaudible] had completed
a drawing
of his wife Lilly Ann in 1926.
[inaudible] asked [inaudible]
if he would come to Pittsburgh
to paint several portraits.
[inaudible] thus made his
first visit to the U.S
for commissions including
Edgar [inaudible] portrait
which now hangs in the
dining room at Falling Water.
[inaudible] became interested
in the printing project,
decided to support the
effort allowing [inaudible]
to build a second press
and asked [inaudible]
with Mrs. [inaudible] urging
to take their son, Edgar Jr.,
on as an apprentice
in his art studio.
In addition to [inaudible] the
studio included Fritz Cradle
who had been a student
of Rudolph [inaudible],
Fritz Arnold from
the [inaudible] house
and young [inaudible].
Then in later 1929, with a
need for larger quarters,
the [inaudible] moved to
a villa in [inaudible],
on the south side
of the [inaudible].
The press finally completed
and the printing finally done,
was named the [inaudible]
because a worn
and nameless statue of a
little saint in a niche
by the villa's entrance
was the little [inaudible]
and the photograph, one of the
photographs there on the right
of the tale show the niche.
In addition to spending some of
the summer at count [inaudible],
the family also came
to the summer home
of the [inaudible] family.
Conrad [inaudible], scion of
an Austrian industrial family,
spent most of his
time in [inaudible],
one of the small Austrian lakes
in the western [inaudible] area
where many Viennese
families summered.
[inaudible] was a collector of
steerian folk sounds and dances
and a [inaudible] expert on
the dialect of this region.
Here, [inaudible] met numerous
friends including Austrian
dramatist and poet Hugo von
[inaudible], the Frankenstein's,
and Gabrielle von [inaudible]
who, at whose [inaudible],
wrote his important works.
[inaudible] daughter, Veronica,
would later marry the
Baron [inaudible],
grandson of Gabrielle.
At [inaudible], worked
on temperate paintings
on parchment depicting
Austrian peasants
in traditional costumes.
[inaudible] shared with
[inaudible] and [inaudible],
his interest in folklore
and local customs and many
of his friends from the area
posed for these paintings.
[ Background noise ]
>> DR. PAUL EVANS HOLBROOK:
Other paintings completed
in these years were those
of Baron [inaudible]
with the [inaudible]
in the background.
Francesca [inaudible],
the wife of his friend
and pet Delfino [inaudible] and
[inaudible], the wife of well,
his friend as well as the
wife of his friend Alexander.
In all these, in addition
to perfect finish obtained
by the use of temper,
there is another attribute.
It is the brush or the
tuning fork in the hands
of the painter, the decorative
medallion in the portrait
of [inaudible], the geometric
pendant in the, on the chain
of Madam [inaudible] glass orb
or the twigs of an olive branch
at the side of the
Austrian ambassador.
All these attributes are not
merely aesthetic embellishments,
but symbolic forms ornamenting
the work with increased meaning
and binding it into
a visible whole.
In 1932, Rosa [inaudible] and
children returned to Vienna
and [inaudible] returned to
London where he had hoped
to get further commissions
from friends of Kenneth Clark,
[inaudible] and Frankenstein.
[inaudible] completed
several [inaudible] portraits
and works in silver point.
He was commissioned
by a committee headed
by Baron Frankenstein to create
a bronze memorial bust for,
in honor of [inaudible] and to
cut a marble inscription for it,
placing it in the
[inaudible] house in Salzburg,
later destroyed by the Nazis.
He had several shows, was
well received in the press,
but the public did
not fulfill his hopes.
At the end of 1932
he left for Paris
where he'd met his old friends,
Tutor and Don Wilkinson.
Of Don, [inaudible]
said I was asked
to paint the most
beautiful woman
in the world, but I failed.
She had been so [inaudible]
when she was
in [inaudible] before
world war 1
and now she refused
the painting finding it
to austere, or statue like.
He also painted some
of his nicest female
portraits during this visit.
His subjects were mostly
friends and [inaudible] cousins
of Antoinette [inaudible].
In 1934.
[ Background noise ]
>> DR. PAUL EVANS HOLBROOK:
On the way back to Austria
from Paris, [inaudible] stopped
at [inaudible] near up Strasburg
to visit his patrons and
friends, the [inaudible] family.
They were close friends
of Thomas [inaudible]
and his wife [inaudible].
They became converted
to Roman Catholicism
and thought it their duty
to build a small chapel
on their own property,
adjacent to the Parish Church
which then did and
now still does,
serve both Protestants
and Catholics.
[inaudible] knowing the task was
possible, offered his services
and was offered the job.
The remarkable thing about the
chapel is that is showcases all
of Victor's skills and talents.
It incorporates his
philosophy and world view.
He created it as a prism with
a quarter prism on top, a door,
a window, all out
of local stone used
for the cathedral in Strasburg.
He worked alongside the masons,
sculptured figures on each side
of the door, crafted all
the interior appointments,
drew plans for the stone
altar, the holy water fount,
the candlesticks and chalice.
He painted the ceiling
beams and finally,
was able to place a crucifix
over the altar upon his
return to Europe in 1957.
He worked on the
chapel for 2 years.
While there, he carved into
the marble library mantle
at [inaudible] suggestion.
Thomas [inaudible]
requirements were a work of art,
beauty and truth, refined
from Aristotle, [inaudible],
reflecting the wholeness, the
unity of the work, its harmony
and its rhythm which
combine to reveal a radiance
that arrests the eye, stills
the mind and enchants the heart.
True art, genuine art, is thus
the vehicle for transformation
for spiritual growth
because is made whole
through an integrating
spiritual gesture.
It lifts us up to
apprehend the sublime.
In 1935, [inaudible]
received an award
by the Austrian government,
the golden medallion
from the [inaudible] house
for services to the arts.
In summer of 36, [inaudible]
was asked by Anna [inaudible],
Conrad's widow, to
come to [inaudible]
and to direct a school organized
as a workshop with apprentices
and funded by the Vienna
Academy of Fine Arts.
His school offered classes
in painting, printing,
book binding, calligraphy, wood
working and cabinet making.
[inaudible] again
established his press
and the school operated
for 2 years.
In 1937, [inaudible] was
offered a post at the Academy
of fine Arts in Vienna and he
accepted the offer in early 38.
He established his press
then in Vienna, but by March,
the German annexation
of Austria was complete.
[ Background noise ]
>> DR. PAUL EVANS HOLBROOK: A
former student at the academy,
now the German chancellor and
head of the Austrian government.
[inaudible] had been a member
of a politically conservative
organization opposed
to the annexation which was
the reason the academy gave
when they notified him that
he could no longer teach.
He was allowed to retain
his studio temporarily.
He and his family
began a waiting game,
but at least nobody every
attacked Victor's art
as degenerate.
In august 1939, he was retired
indefinitely from the academy.
[inaudible] was afraid
he would be coopted
as a propaganda artist for the
3rd Reich and knew he could not
at any rate work under the
Nazi yolk with any freedom.
In the spring of 39, he's
already writing to Edward Bruce
at the WPA, Fritz Cradle now in
self-imposed exile in New York,
Nicholas [inaudible] then
teaching at Well's College
and [inaudible] and the
Wilkinson's in France.
Warned by American
friends and beginning
to realize completely the
political consequences
of remaining in Austria,
[inaudible] was willing
to face economic
insecurity abroad.
[inaudible] succeeded in
getting [inaudible] a position
in the art department at Well's
College in September of 39.
He and Rosa left for [inaudible]
as if for a weekend trip,
painting on the German general's
portrait that was on his,
I mean the Austrian generals
portrait that was on his easel
in the studio, a
little Hitler mustache.
[inaudible] had arranged a
travel by ship and they sailed
for New York without
anything but a bag,
arriving in September of 39.
At Well's, [inaudible]
assumed his professorship
and not having any of
his own type, typographer
and printer Joseph [inaudible]
in New York, gave him some
of his spiral type to use.
While at Wells,
victor established the
Well's college press.
He became an American citizen
in 1945, cut the 14-point size
of the American [inaudible]
type.
In [inaudible], he completed
3 panels and this portrait
of [inaudible] who was
a ballerina and head
of the [inaudible]
foundation in New York.
The Austrian peasant saint,
Saint Notburga, commissioned
by Maria von Trap, also in exile
in the United States as well
as a mythological panel of the
hunchback Aesop and [inaudible],
and a panel of depicting
Christ and the money changers.
In 1948, the renaissance society
at the University of Chicago
under the direction of
[inaudible] old friend
from Florence, [inaudible],
arranged a retrospective exhibit
of [inaudible] work at
the Newberry library.
Raymond McClain, president
of Transylvania College
in Lexington and its board
share Joseph [inaudible] were
especially invited.
[inaudible] was nearing
mandatory retirement at Wells
and [inaudible] of the
[inaudible] foundry
who had known victor and was
a friend of [inaudible] along
with other Chicago friends hoped
Transylvania might call victor's
artist in residence.
McClain and Graves were amazed
at the depth and breadth
of victor's talent and craft
and immediately did invite him
to come to Lexington
without consulting any
of the Transylvania
board members.
[inaudible] accepted and
with only a hand shake,
it was settled.
As McClain later said
in an oral history,
we did things differently
in those days.
And so, in the fall of 1948,
[inaudible] began his position
as artist in residence
at Transylvania College
in Lexington, Kentucky.
Established his press, now
with his own American
[inaudible] type,
the [inaudible] again operated
and began its run
in the bluegrass.
[inaudible] time in
Lexington was peaceful.
Of course, he acquired a new
circle of friends and patrons.
Teaching, and as a result
without any financial worry,
he could work on projects
that we wanted to do.
Rosa [inaudible] died in 1954.
The following year, [inaudible]
married their mutual,
well their friend,
Caroline [inaudible]
who had been Victor's apprentice
and helped Rosa during
her final illness.
He cut the 18-point American
[inaudible] in Lexington
and the 14 point
[inaudible] type.
He completed 5 portraits
including one of Raymond McClain
and our Kentucky
[inaudible], John Jacob Niles.
He painted 8 panels on
[inaudible], crucifixes,
3 different versions
of varying size.
One for the chapel
in [inaudible],
one for Thomas Merton who wanted
it in his [inaudible] chapel
at [inaudible] and another
one that he retained himself.
He did the 4th and 5th versions
of Christ and the adulteress
and these 2 tryptic on the
left crowning the young Christ
and memory and her 9 daughters,
the muses, and he worked on,
but did not finish his lass
tryptic, the resurrection.
Do I have time to say
something on [inaudible]?
[ Background noise ]
>> DR. PAUL EVANS HOLBROOK:
Are we doing all right?
Well, the [inaudible] Sophia
was commissioned as a Madonna
and child and as Victor
was working on it,
the child became a young man
and the woman, the Madonna,
became almost Amazonian
in proportion.
And Thomas Merton came to
the dentist in Lexington,
which was a way that
he could escape
and see his friends
[inaudible] and at lunch,
Merton was observing the panel
on the easel and he said,
who are these people and
victor said I no longer know.
Merton thought of the line from
proverbs, Wisdom will honor you
if you love her, she will place
on your head a fair garland,
she will crown you
with a crown of glory.
And so, Merton said this
is [inaudible] Sophia
and crowing the young Christ.
Merton then wrote his little
meditation on the holy hours
of the day called
[inaudible] Sophia.
In the muses, which is in, at
the University of San Francisco,
Victor did something
that he often did do,
make use of his former sitter's
faces in another context
and Mrs. Tudor Wilkinson
[inaudible] as the head
of Urania and when Victor
told her she was going to be
in his tryptic she wrote a post
card and said oh dear Victor,
I'm so happy I'm in your tryptic
when my body is moldering
in the ground, my, I will
still be measuring the skies.
[inaudible] was awarded
an honorary doctor
of humanities degree by the
University of [inaudible]
in 1960 in the North Carolina
Museum of Art at Raleigh mounted
in retrospective
exhibition in 1965.
[inaudible] died in Lexington
on the 10th of July 1967.
Raymond McClain, former
president of Transylvania,
read the burial service
concluding
with this final evaluation.
It was his genius to unify
these gifts in his life.
He made no distinctions so far
as I can tell between the arts
and the crafts, even more
between the fine arts
and the supposed
lesser categories.
There was just as much artistry,
just a much craftsmanship,
just as much attention to
composition, just as marriage
with form and function, just
as much discipline, technique
and production, whether
the work were carpentry
or punch cutting or painting.
This gave Victor the power
of undivided wholeness
and reduced potential
complexity to simplicity.
These are attributes
of genius and results
of enormous self-discipline
exercised over the years.
He's lifted his work to
the level of the universal,
lifted it above the moment
and gave it to the ages.
Let us make no mistake about
Victor, he was a simple man,
but it was an achieved
simplicity.
He was a highly sophisticated
person,
well read in several languages,
conversed with the
best minds ever
to have reduced their
thoughts to poetry
or prose on the printed page.
His simplicity was the
result of education,
of continuing thought.
His technique embodied
a constant search
for better ways of doing things.
His power was rooted in a
highly sensitized intuition,
refined by unremitting
work and dedicated
to a purpose beyond his
immediate personal status.
It is no accident that
he worked [inaudible],
the moto which was carved in
the portico of the Jesuit church
in Vienna which had
overshadowed his childhood gains
and nurtured his
life as an artist.
He paid the price to
deserve this distinction.
He could be so withdrawn
from the world because he was
so thoroughly its product.
And this is a late
portrait of our [inaudible],
collector of folk songs and
musician John Jacob Niles
and completely, accidentally,
Johnny's 126th birthday is
Saturday and the friends
in Lexington have contributed
to an historical marker
to be placed on the
[inaudible] road at Boot Hill,
the Nile's farm in Clark County.
And Victor, and this
is a perfect example
of Victor's portraits here.
Everyone looks far more austere
than they were in reality
and there's another similar
portrait of the mayor
of Louisville, Charlie Farnsley
who was just a terrible comedian
and yet he looks very
dignified in the picture.
So, that's all I have to
say, but I'll be happy
to answer any questions
if I can.
[ Background noise ]
>> ERIC FRAZIER: If we
have questions then please
and afterward we can take a
look at some of the material
that Paul has brought
up for us to see
that compliments the topic.
>> DR. PAUL EVANS HOLBROOK:
Thank you for coming.
>> What was it that
offended the Nazis,
that required the [inaudible].
>> DR. PAUL EVANS
HOLBROOK: Well,
[inaudible] didn't
have to leave.
He just felt because he knew
he would not have any artistic
freedom and he had no intention
of becoming a propaganda artist
which his paintings,
as it were idealized,
figures would have been
perfect for the Nazi program.
>> Did he [inaudible]?
>> DR. PAUL EVANS HOLBROOK: Yes,
but he was forbidden to teach.
The excuse was that he belonged
to this conservative party
that was against the annexation.
So, there was really no reason
that they needed to fire him,
but I'm sure, but
it happily worked
out to everyone's advantage
except the [inaudible]
which was replaced by the.
I showed the original memorial
was a bust from the waist up
and the marble plaque underneath
it and Victor had had a head,
just the head cast for
him to keep at the time
of the original casting and
they were able to make a mold
from the cast head and recast
another head that I'm told is
in the [inaudible]
house again in Salzburg,
but I haven't yet seen it.
I hope to get to
Salzburg before too long.
>> Another question.
Was the relationship of the
[inaudible] long standing?
>> DR. PAUL EVANS HOLBROOK: Yes.
Well, it was very important.
It allowed him, the press,
to really be started.
Edgar Sr. gave Victor I think
$400 a month for 2 years
and Edgar Jr. After, then
the depression hit of course
and Edgar Jr. said I'm getting
an allowance from father,
I will have it and
give you half of it.
He was still there in
the studio, which he did,
and Edgar Jr. although,
you know,
he had this fabulous
art collection,
but it was mostly contemporary
works, but he had these several.
I mean, he was devoted to Victor
and wrote a very nice meditation
for the 3rd volume the
[inaudible] press publication
Victor [inaudible], an artist's
testament about his time
and his experience
in the studio.
And he, when Victor died,
he sent the large portrait
of Victor to Caroline
of, which he had in his,
stored away somewhere
probably with the paint brush
and the [inaudible] on which
Caroline then donated along
with the silver point
and the, that one copy
of the [inaudible] self-portrait
to the national portrait
gallery.
So, it's here somewhere and
would be nice to see it again.
But, so yes, the
[inaudible] were and Caroline
and Edgar Jr. corresponded
till he died.
>> Those are preserved?
[inaudible].
>> DR. PAUL EVANS HOLBROOK:
Oh yes, the art isn't.
The correspondence
should be here,
all the [inaudible]
correspondence.
The Wilkinson correspondence,
the [inaudible] correspondence,
there's over, Victor.
I mean, there's over
400, I think,
envelopes of correspondence
in the collection here.
>> ERIC FRAZIER: So, part of
Paul's coming to give this talk
and talk [inaudible]
tomorrow is, is also a bit
of a celebration in
rehousing and publishing
and posting the revised binding
[inaudible] for the collection.
And so, the collection
is broke up into,
it's a wonderful collection.
We have correspondence exhibits,
exhibit publications,
photographs.
>> DR. PAUL EVANS HOLBROOK:
Reviews and critiques.
>> ERIC FRAZIER: As well
as some artifacts and some
of his printing blocks.
And yeah, so that's [inaudible]
collection exists here
at the [inaudible] and
special collections.
It was posted earlier this week
and the entire finding
is available online.
It's ready and waiting
for researchers.
>> DR. PAUL EVANS HOLBROOK: And
I will come and research again.
We sent the boxes away in a
Mayflower moving truck to come
to Washington in 1988
and then I came back,
what was it, 4 years ago?
Oh dear.
[ Background noise ]
>> DR. PAUL EVANS HOLBROOK:
Doesn't seem as long,
but at any rate, came back
and helped make it get the,
get things filed away which we.
I came on Wednesday
and left on Saturday
and we had it basically all
in order by the time I left.
>> ERIC FRAZIER:
Assembly line up of.
>> DR. PAUL EVANS
HOLBROOK: Several helpers.
Yes Mam.
>> Where are the presses now?
>> DR. PAUL EVANS
HOLBROOK: Well,
mysteriously the 2
wooden presses were left
in Victor's studio in
Vienna when he left in 39.
Mysteriously, one of
them found its way the
to the Gutenberg's last
house in [inaudible].
So, it's a part of
the collection there.
The other wooden press is
at the King Library Press.
It along with a lot of
things from the studio came
to Lexington in 1955
and friends of Victor's
in Lexington bought the wooden
press from him and donated it
to the King Library for use
in the press there in order
to help support Victor's
life in Lexington.
And the, Victor had an
iron press at Wells College
which was left there and the,
we, they reopened the press
in 1993 I think and it
is, they have a curator
who comes I think every
other year, a hummer fellow,
a printer who comes
and does work there.
And Victor got an iron press
in, after he came to Lexington
which he, which is still in
Lexington with Caroline's nephew
who also learned to print.
>> The wooden presses
were [inaudible].
>> DR. PAUL EVANS HOLBROOK:
There is a press still
in the [inaudible] Library
in Florence that was thought,
when Victor drew the, copied
the, drew the plans for it,
though to be the 15th century
Remundy Press and [inaudible],
who it was and I've showed
she's no longer there,
I mean long dead, at the
library, proved more or less
to everyone's satisfaction
that it was an Napoleonic copy
of the original Remundy press.
But, still, an old
press and its,
Victor and [inaudible] did
a very nice job with it.
It's a beautiful
press and we use it.
I just had a student this
semester who wanted to do a poet
in MFA candidate in poetry
did a, wanted to do a poem
and used the wooden
press to do the poem.
He wanted to, we happened
to have a Buick woodcut,
a small heron, tiny
one that Bob Middleton
who had accumulated a large
collection of Buick cuts
and at his cherry
burn press in Chicago,
printed 2 different
volumes of Buick images.
So, we use the image of the
heron in this, with this poem.
And I thought the wooden press
would be the gentlest way
to print this lock that was done
in 1730 or whenever it was done.
So, we're, we are still
very much using the press
and I have Caroline, when
she, we quit printing,
the last book we printed
at the anvil press
which was her final imprint,
Thomas Merton's 4 poems
in French and Merton having
been born in Prague, France.
And she gave me the press and
the contents of the press room
and I transferred them to the
King Library where I assume
as long as it lasts, will be.
I mean, I will eventually
completely donate it
to the King Library
unless they close the press
and I have to take it home.
But, I imagine in my old age
going to the press and using it
as long as I please even
if I'm no longer there.
So.
[ Background noise ]
>> DR. PAUL EVANS
HOLBROOK: Well, I hope you.
Thank you.
I hope you feel as if you
have met Victor [inaudible]
in part, at least partially.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.